[Music]
so
too
[Music]
that's
do
[Music]
so
all the pieces you know it's funny you
say that actually
it's funny you say that because in my
discord yesterday this got posted
and it was like this is going to be
cjm's plan
for the event right and i was like what
what is this
image so like i pulled it up and i was
like well
uh you know this is a powerful this is
my
plan of attack i've got one plan and one
plan alone
you think you can stop me i'm gonna show
up punch everybody to
death by the way working from home so
you know business up top
parties down low right i'm wearing gym
shorts here full disclosure
this is connor the guy with the is it
fair to say you have the sexiest voice
in a
voice in anime
[Laughter]
just tell me still
[Music]
thank you thank you jesus
[Laughter]
yes i have i [__] up ah
good game gone i can't believe god
nearly threw at the end that king
that king moved i'm pretty sure
my blind grandma wouldn't make that king
move god
but what's that move i don't need shady
tactics
i don't need underhanded ploys what i
need
is the loyalty to my lineage
to the people who brought me from the
ground up
who believed in me when i didn't even
believe in myself jt
today i'm making you i'm making you
proud
it seems i've made a great error in
judgment
i really want to see what ollie's
thinking here and what she's calculating
i hope that she sees the check but uh
let's see
can i can i can i just say can i just
call out connor right now because i
think i know he's watching i know he's
watching he titled definitely watching
he titled his stream
watching ollie play chess what about me
dude
i thought you were friends i've slept on
your floor man
[Laughter]
all right that has a nice little recap
there of uh
week one what's up jt how's it going man
how's it going oh man that was a great
video
it was so so amazing i love that
how did you even do that i need some
lessons if you're watching i need
lessons
yeah ali is going to need to make like a
youtube tutorial
of how to do all the
the good stuff that was fantastic we've
had such a great opening
week to tournament arc and uh
uh and we have more in store today
we've got a couple matches that i think
the audience is going to really love
featuring of course the one and only
craigie ollie
and she's going to be playing against
cdoc va i mean
this is something this is something that
i think
a good amount of people have been hoping
to see
just because they know that the love
between
sea dog and ollie is strong and
uh i don't know that they've actually
ever spoken
like live before i i know they speak
about each other
but i don't actually think they've ever
been in a stream together so this is
gonna be
this is gonna be a world first for
for the two of them and i know they're
stoked to uh to meet each other
uh and we also have
techtone versus esam which is gonna be
an exciting match and we're gonna see
if the hippo uh has what it takes
i'm talking about the opening guys
that's what it takes
to to defeat e sam who
is gonna have to throw his pieces
against uh against this
pretty strong opening jt what do you
think is gonna happen
in that uh in that later match today
i don't know um the hippo the hippo
match
um
hippo i mean he sounds the best pikachu
can you take it on the hippo right he
detector explained that you know he was
a grandma
and he put on that so hopefully it's a
good matchup honestly
i i just want to see the hippo being
played and being played effectively
i don't want him to move so fast and i
want him to calculate just like he did
in the second
game um versus kizzy that's what i need
him to play
and hopefully the hippo prevails and if
it does great
and if it doesn't i'm still gonna be
proud of him you know i just want
some good shots yeah i think we're gonna
get some good chests it'll definitely be
a test
and uh however sea dog and ollie i'm not
sure what we're gonna get there today
but
whatever it's gonna be it's gonna be
great let's uh let's make sure that
everybody understands what we're gonna
do here
so tournament arc 2 itself is a double
elimination bracket there's a winner's
half there's a redemption half
and one person from each of those halves
is going to come together in a grand
final
to win the uh the big old prize and
bragging rights as the champion
of tournament arc 2. the games
themselves will be 10 minutes per
uh per player and then they will gain
five seconds every time they make a move
it'll be a best of three match so the
first to two points
wins their pairing and uh if somehow
they both end up with one and a half
points
uh after three games then we will go
into a tie break match up three minutes
per player and no increment whatsoever
so we're going to see some crazy fast
chests
and uh there's some money at stake first
place is gonna walk away with four
thousand dollars second place twenty
five hundred
third place fifteen hundred fourth eight
hundred fifth through eight
three hundred dollars uh and uh this is
actually double the prize fund that we
had for tournament arc one
which uh is awesome and of course
chess.com was
uh was uh
putting a lot of faith in us jt to do a
tournament arc too and make it exciting
for people and uh i don't know i have to
say so far
i think the players have done the work
for us in making this event
worth every penny of chess.com's money
what do you think
um wait what they were expecting me to
do something
i thought i was just scared i had to be
pretty just leave me on screen
oh no i mean why do you think i'm here
that's the only thing i can provide is
my
charm i got it okay okay okay okay great
great okay let's
i need a break because uh we need to
talk about strategy then
oh my goodness are we about to lose our
jobs okay we're gonna be right back
and when we come back we'll have the
first games of the day
crazy ollie versus sea dog va stick
around uh
i think jt and i are about to go on
indeed.com during the break
and we'll see everybody in just a sec
you've an ama all right hold up
when did you get the where did you get
the emea shirt
shiro shirt one of them my mom got it
for me i don't know where it's from
though i think it's like jack jones i
think it's called
uh but yeah i can't remember i've got to
trim my mustache that's why it looks so
different
oh i'm gonna go do that i gotta remind
myself
damn connor so swag dude i look like a
porn star what do you mean
bruh
i don't know like through my mustache
it's so thick
so thick
corner has drip
you look even wider [__] my life
maybe i'll uh go down to the barn you
know and do that kind of stuff
whatever those people do at barnes i
don't know let me think some subs let me
get through all the subs
monkey man bob thank you for stopping
people's things over nine months well
connor our freak monkey baby is almost
here
oh jesus christ uh eight months uh more
terry thank you so much three months mop
head two seven one two three four months
captain sugar buns in three months vale
roano i think in the four months red
fury prime thank you
or something uh frozen characters in
three months monkey versus zombie let's
go dar i think you're the
gifted sub first there's 70 they get
four months
ah scissor tion
3 months infinite loop thank you shrek
the ogre i think we're selling
zero scallop nine eight eight nine thank
you sobbing camoy 26 things on
h g j v c g they stop incur
diamond things over four bites you got
this thank you to the k thank you for
subbing
neander thank you soon peppa chronos 37
ah cold light use of two months
76 million three months read the tree
lovely thing you saw
in some random infant thank you for
stopping
osmandia's works things for three months
until to japan from the us for the end
of
january or the other coveted
restrictions are lifted
and by then 40
chance japan is real strict about it
right now
uh walking beer boo i think something
two months
probably see you lose to ollie i
wouldn't even be mad arrow 101 thinks
something
see benny nation except for four months
brainstorm traveling giving out a sub
lilly ray thinking something jamaican
bacon thing 77 oh
darth caleb i think he's saying jesse
lineal thinking something for nine
months probably leaving the four
mega dev one number seven and clash
street thank you son all right there we
go we got it
did you get that sweet drip from meg
welding
sadly not uh granite i think the five
packs as well green from pittsburgh love
the new cost video so i'm once again
going to suggest
mars and the planets as a shad piece of
classical music
playing chess mars from the planet is
that royalty free
all right all these i always streaming
is all i have look
[Music]
uh royal the three
i don't see any royalty free versions
well this sounds like a recovery i don't
know if it's copyrighted
i'll find one that's not i know what's
all we do
my manager is giving me um
my manager is giving me such a big
support she couldn't come oh no
i feel bad
reality is uh not as simple as my side i
root for my side
this is a tian suzation cessation thing
with the five salesmen dude
uh ascent w thank you for subbing gsg
epiphany things seven i recognize them
for two months
i'm not i'm not i'm not
uh i'm not hoping very much so i just i
i'll just have fun you know i'll just
enjoy my first ever collab with
connor somewhat just realize how he's
using rainey's bdm yeah because it's
calming isn't it
it's nice
i can't hear it though only you guys can
hear it i don't want to get
too distracted
i love manager son hi d2 i love her so
much
so doesn't it look cute i'm all blue now
even though i'm red it's a contrast
button yes button senpai's bgm
now i'll change it to jojo bgm you see
unlike connor i have this thing called
copyright i don't want to be copyrighted
when i lose today we're all very proud
of you and all your hard work and effort
that's why you'll be a champion
regardless
knock on dead zombie girl oh thank you
thank you so much wolfie 10 12.
ah we're going to start soon so i will
turn off the live chat okay
i can align
um let's go good luck thank you come on
ollie thank you good luck thank you
mandy tears are naturally best girl well
she is good luck
luck you've got this holy believe in god
senpai
okay i'm turning off the live chat now
because we're starting in one minute
and it is off thank you so much everyone
all right ollie's chat is off her head
is on tight it is gonna be a match
in 60 seconds or so um
dude this is uh this could be fantastic
i i'm ready to start my day with
start my day it makes it sound like i
just woke up which i didn't
i swear what time is it
well it's time for the first match to
get underway right
oh yes i'm super excited
that is the time i i think it's time i
think the moves are being made and
it's game one of
day five yesterday day five what
okay you're in charge jt
you're in charge uh i don't think sea
dog
knows that the game has started
oh no are we gonna get a forfeit here or
you guys couldn't even see oh no no no
this is it right
oh my god
whole minute or hold 30 seconds has
transpired
[Music]
it's picking jams
is he giving time odds here
hi this is my kind of song now i can
play chess
thank you
i can't play chess without the
appropriate music guys come on
interesting
[Music]
conor not opting for the jojo music this
time
[Music]
i think the jojo music actually hindered
him last time
so it's kind of unfortunate like it was
supposed to be his hype music but then
it ended up being his downfall so i
think the change to classical music
is was a good change yeah and we'll see
uh so what what kind of effect that has
on his chest today
um this is
these these pieces seem
strangely assembled right now
yeah basically what all he's saying is
i'm gonna keep developing my pieces
uh and maybe maybe you want to play like
b3 bishop b2
and they're uniquely placed i wouldn't
want to say bat
right they're just unique unique okay
maybe that's what my teachers in
elementary school met when they kept
telling me i was unique
over and over again every day
no no no but it's not it's not a bad
setup actually the bishop on d3 even
though it's
hindering the pawn the bishop on d3 is
hitting the pawn on d2
going to the center i mean we can still
put this bishop on these two lines and
it's kind of dangerous
if conor decides to castle uh kingside
so
we have to be very very aware very
careful
so
[Music]
like people would think oh she's a
youtuber we never know what she's
looking at we can't see
her her facial expressions well guess
what
i'm not cheating thank you for being so
nice connor
connor you're so nice thank you
i'll just do that
i can't i can't eat the bishop because
there's distant guarding it
yeah a bit
we are back and the game has progressed
jt um what is the situation
like right now on the board
in your words well we in words okay
sure um not in all this word
right and so right now the queen is
pinning this knight to the king
there was a free queen earlier but conor
for some reason decided not to take the
queen
and um maybe play nice
and move another piece but here um
black is just winning a piece and you
cannot recapture he
after the recapture oops sorry this way
you cannot recapture this way because
after
takes here queen takes
and it's a check and we also win the
rook
so you can't even take the pawn back
because then you fall into
another fork yeah there's
tactics everywhere and uh sea dog
is playing patiently though he's got his
other rook going
and uh listening to some calm
gems let's uh let's check in with cdog
here
nice
ollie goes zoom
uh okay
that's interesting i think her preferred
term is whoosh
i i think the other preferred phrase is
uh
you have upseti the spaghetti
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is this is jt that's the one that
i'm taking i
i think the chat is right i think this
is a nice game
yeah this is a really calm game i mean
o'connor
is up a piece but so far so good
uh it's not something that you cannot
come back from
the bishop the light squared bishop both
of them are
you know they're about even in strength
although this one's being attacked right
now
uh if we see a trade of those then it
might go downhill for all these so ollie
maybe just needs to not trade them
and the one square i'm seeing right now
is
if we turn off these bishops
or just take the bishop for free um then
we can get a knight here and then
when the light knight is here it's
probably one of the most powerful pieces
on the board it's actually probably
stronger than this rook
because it controls so many squares
yeah agreed and let's uh let's take
another peek in at ali's perspective
here
i only have two rooks left
where do i go from here
boom he has two rooks two horses and one
bishop
you know what let's call these pieces
something else it's getting hard for me
to
like you know what let's call you duke
you are the duke
you're going to be the marquis right so
i'm going to make you the baron
and maybe you can make it the baroness
and you're going the other one is the
marquianness and you're the duchess
or you know you can be like the viscount
and you're the countess
the marquis and what do you call a
female did it look like the what
what does it call it again
i really want to try it check meeting
him once
i really want to try check meeting him
just once
like if connor is nice he'll give me the
checkmate
he'll probably be like oh no ollie
checked me
darn she had me i'm so proud of her
she's doing such a great job and then
he'll he'll like wreck me in the next
two rounds
i have eight whole minutes
and he has uh four and a half actually
i'm
i have eight and a half minutes and he
has four and a half
well not anymore he has uh four and a
quarter
[Music]
hmm
sure i'm not risking this i
i'm just i just don't want to embarrass
myself here
all right nice
i i'm actually trying very hard because
i just i just don't want to make an
embarrassing blunder
let's do it
oh
safe i'm very safe
[Music]
making it so annoying all right
unfortunately
ollie's uh duke duchess
uh whatever it was she named it it fell
uh with bishop taking there and uh
yep conor is up a good amount of
material
but not a lot of time i mean look three
and a half minutes how did that happen
so this was a game plan for connor
i told him he needs to take a little bit
more time
in the opening even if he knew what he
wanted to play
double triple check because in chess
there's no take backs
you make a mistake it is game over
so you can play faster later right when
you're
when you're at four minutes five minutes
but try to get that early advantage
first and then you're just going to win
simple as that play is going to be
easier
yeah and definitely the case here that
pawn is gonna
get a free ride all the way to becoming
a queen and uh
i wonder how ollie feels about how this
first game has gone
oh my god i'm losing whoa
whoa oh my god i'm checked
um do this
and he's going to bring his queen up
that's what i thought
wait if i go there
oh no it's a check it's a checkmate he's
going to bring his phone out oh
that happens
[Music]
he had me at
hey at least you didn't sound too upset
about it you know what i mean
i don't know that after winning a
tournament game or losing a tournament
game
that i'd be able to just go ah
he's checking me oh i'm being checkmated
but what if the plot armor is so thick
that ollie makes a comeback here
that's true we saw that happened in the
first
um game again no in the second game
against wrestling right where
it just happened and the plot armor is
trying to take us down right now
and it seems to keep calling us
on skype when we told them not to call
us on skype
because it crashes the stream but it
keeps doing it but so
the holy plot armor is trying to come
through you have to answer
because that plot armor be thick though
we'll be right back
[Music]
he wasn't going to give away the check
he wasn't going to give away to check it
out
it was it was a bit sad
yeah i should have eaten with my
[Music]
marquees
let's focus and check before you move
yeah right
right right right right that's what we
should do ah
darn he got me
oh no oh no
[Laughter]
if nothing this is fun to watch i'm glad
that you guys are at least entertained
come and thank ollie take your time
take your time no rush okay i'll do that
what if what if i take like five minutes
for like one move
wouldn't that be kind of funny
next time one speed racer think all you
think
geez y'all you can still win everyone's
being so nice
concentrate right conor made lots of
mistakes during that game
either he made lots of mistakes or he
let me
off the blunders like i made so many
blenders
kind of makes mistakes
hit him with a warhammer okay we have an
objective
now uh i don't have any hopes of
checking him
but i plan on destroying his morale by
eating his queen i want to do that
if you start to lose flip the board
i can't flip the blade
two minutes good luck players thank you
admin son
all set for heroes come back moment
there's no mistakes but happy accidents
happy accidents play some anime music
copyright
can't do that
go holly go fluffy's here favorite thank
you so much for coming
hey you're always in my streams i love
you so much
thank you veve everyone give it up for
the vid
wait is is forever indie is fifa an
indie youtuber
or are you in an agency not i'm not here
but give it up for
feather she's really cool
we're starting in one more minute so
i'll be turning off the live chat now
bye everyone bye bye
you can do it let's go thank you
and save it the live chat is now off
that was a quick five minutes
i didn't even get to catch a breath
that was a fast five minutes and we're
back
wow time flies when you're having fun
right jt oh yeah
um and i think i'm gonna need an only
sound board
i just want when they got me uh yeah
that's all i want to play in my
background
i think in a popping sound whenever i'm
thinking yes hollow live
i think you have a new product the ali
sound board it's like a stream deck and
all the buttons are pre-loaded with
everything that's already happened just
in tournament arc 2 alone
uh but ladies and gentlemen the time is
nigh
we will have game two coming up in just
a second it's going to kick off
at any moment and we'll start off with
uh looking at c-dog
all right nice nice idea
[Music]
conor might be tempting the plot armor
with that music jt
oh no i would just stay with the
classical music
i don't know why the switch maybe he's
feeling himself
um
and ollie here giving the early check i
normally don't like this although
you know it does put the bishop on a bad
square the bishop does not belong on d2
so maybe there's a little bit of prep
here hmm
who knows maybe saying this this bishop
is going to stay bad forever
this is a very interesting uh ploy there
yeah and
the other possibility there maybe was
that conor would play
c3 to kick the bishop but then now
you've moved that pawn and it can't go
backwards later
um i actually do like to play those
moves sometimes in certain openings
to tempt them to make a pawn move that
later might present a weakness that i
can then exploit so
you know i don't know one way or the
other whether or not that was ollie's
intention but uh let's listen and see
uh i'm kind of ruining the castle
maybe the king could castle here i mean
a little lift is never
it never hurts to have a little lift
right
my goodness that scared me bam boom
i got one of his puns i'm doing so well
oh that scared me crystal
magic crystal
uh
yeah let's try getting this out too
yup it
now i can go here right
because if i eat this then you'll eat
with your prime minister
prime minister marquis i keep changing
the bishop's name i'm very sorry
the bishop with many names
blah blah
okay what can i do here let's take a
look-see let's take our time you guys
told me to take my time i'll take my
time
what will happen if we drag this we'll
get eaten um
we can get our queen out but i think
that's still too soon
jt what's your favorite the the marquee
the uh the the prime minister
which ones have been your favorite so
far
i think my favorite piece is the marquee
but i don't know which piece
that is because the names keep changing
and just to translate uh what ali was
saying she said
or i was surprised so very
um very interesting because she just
keeps changing from
japanese english and she's
multi-talented um
i i really love that about aldi but in
this game
conor is in the lead and
not really identifying that this bishop
was uh was capturable
ollie had an opportunity there to snatch
off one of uh
conor's marquee prime minister's
uh bishops with many names
as she put it and he draws it back
and now the pegasus is under attack uh
on age six how does
how is conor going to
break through though because
all these pieces are really defending
the king
like like a lot like conor's gonna have
to do some work here it's not it's not
it's not cut and dry just yet
not yet i mean even though honor is
better developed
i think that there's still a lot of play
uh for ollie so you gotta be careful you
gotta you gotta make sure that you
uh try carefully
[Music]
i have no qualms about getting
copyrighted if it's this song
yeah exactly so you two are a fan of the
classics hi sodas
[Music]
all right sorry about that guys
i don't really know what to do this is
such a strange position
i think i just trade the show
and take a free pawn
[Music]
we're getting a bit greedy here with his
greed uh be justified or
i mean maybe at this point he's like i'm
so much material doesn't matter what i
give back
or he's got to be tenacious and he's
going to be careful
yeah and he made a face there he saw
okay i can get a pawn at the end of this
line but then he stopped he's like wait
a minute
uh do i really want to risk it
is he now he's trying to figure out is
it going to get him in trouble
but i don't think it will right you
snatch that pawn and just run away right
i agree with nice e3 i feel like that
pawn is not
worth it i mean either you defend it now
or it's we can take it next turn but i i
believe that knight c3 is a stronger
move because now we have
moves like queen h5 check right and
just show it on the board of queen h
check here attacking the king
right and the king has to move so the
king cannot castle anymore
and we're gonna bring it to the center
and then at that point once we play
queen h5
then we might have a castles and that
brings a rook
to the center and we can then start
attacking the king
so i agree with this move i agree with
this choice this was a
very good choice and sometimes we might
even look to play
after maybe let's say if the king goes
to d7 we have queen f5
and now the king goes back but now our
queen is on a better square
and we potentially have checkmate
opportunities
all right well we'll see i really want
to just i want to see what ollie has to
say here
yeah she uh moves in the direction of
the open corner there
you get the castle i don't that's
good for you man
man good for you i have a lot of people
guarding your king too well my king is
pretty much alone
mind backing off your queen
[Music]
thank you
uh how long should i play next
sounds good
this whole match was a mistake
like i know i i know it seems like i've
given up but i'm actually trying my best
to think but the thing is he keeps on
attacking me i don't have anything to do
man it's 7 00 am here
i haven't slept that well i have i have
a day job
too i didn't slept that well yesterday
i even had to cancel a stream
these matches are so early
okay he he's starting to give me a
chance
he's starting to give me a chance he's
like okay ollie i'm going to back away
i want to see what you do
i think it's more than just giving her a
chance
connor actually seemed a little
hard-pressed to figure out how to
checkmate in there right
yeah i mean i think there was a
checkmate earlier
um but that was a hard checkmate that
fine because he had to sacrifice a piece
but in this
game conor was threatening this move
knight to e6 so now here also
threatening it because the bishop cannot
take
because a knight will take and then it's
going to fork
the king and the queen and you're going
to win
another piece so unfortunately the
bishop cannot take
and uh then ollie's hopes of getting
connor's queen
to shock him will be completely dashed
at that point
and uh right right sea dog
seems to be pretty confident that he's
gonna be moving on
in the competition but he's got to seal
the deal let's see
how he does it
this one is kind of protecting the king
and i don't
what do i do
all he's actually holding on so far
playing defensively
i mean uh she's making connor work
yeah and corner just go for one idea
he's like i want the fork i want the
fork i want the fork that's all i want
and ollie's just not giving it to him
yeah and you could be wasting moves just
continuing to go after that plan what's
interesting also about this game is both
players are
pretty even on time too so ollie's not
necessarily moving as fast as she
usually does
maybe that's because she's playing or
being forced to play more
defensively but hey there it is uh
connor gets the fork that he was looking
for
and uh that is gonna make his job a lot
easier
um is that a bit of korean too
huh
okay
[Music]
all right i'm in check
then you're going to move your queen
can mean a few things but um
usually is like oh no or how did this
happen it could be
either how oh no so
that's our learning languages here with
uh
motion yo
hello
all right nice nice nice
[Music]
this is fun
this is mean though i'm just taking all
of all these pieces
all right we're ready
ready to finish this
like ted what are we to do well i can't
really
the chat is frozen right now but
seriously
what am i to do he's been checking me
left and right
he's been checking me from the left side
on the right side
and then left side right side how much
it
i'm a king
ha
at ha she's in high spirits
if i eat this
the queen can just scoot over
i can't move here
but i can eat the queen
ollie is putting her best foot forward
here despite the fact that she knows
she's probably lost uh she isn't doing
what we might imagine
could be the reaction which is all right
just take all my stuff
okay it's done she's still calculating
okay if he does this i can do that maybe
i can defend this way
create these problems like she's still
working it
i would love to see a seat dog because i
think these are the kind of moments if
he finds a one last move
wow actually yeah couldn't it have been
rook takes
d6 and with the
bishop covering squares the queen
covering squares the knight covering
squares that would have been mate right
there
but you know if uh if this is the sea
dog that we know and love
he likes to miss mate in one it's kind
of his thing
right right that's been his mo so
is this going to be another case of uh
yeah a choke dog v8
let's uh let's find out
[Music]
please
they both have like songs for each other
when the game ended
oh my gosh if that's not love i don't
know what is
am i right am i right
i mean wow what a what an ending and
geez it kind of feels like
ali had a really really good plan which
i think was just playing too fast in the
opening
so she was just ready to like eat her
opponent but
the phone just kept going no no no it's
giving the opponent a lot of things to
eat back so
um i i really want to see ollie like
take her time
um in the later matches i hope to see
her again i hope see you soon i hope
she's
she doesn't stop but obviously continues
to play us and stop playing so fast
uh because i think she would be an
amazing player she did so
because she even though she was
defending a lot of the games
she was holding on and she was finding
good moves
in some situations yeah i think uh
ollie played her best chest in turn mark
two and
we had an absolute wonderful time uh
having her
and we are going to have her and connor
in just a few moments for the interview
so stick around
we'll be right back a lot of the games
she was holding on and she was finding
good moves
in constituents
yeah i think uh ollie was definitely her
best chest in turn mark too
and we had an absolute wonderful time uh
having her and
we are gonna have her and connor in just
a few moments for the interview so stick
around
we'll be right back
am i on stream yeah hi chat or hello
chess.com i am setting up for my game
and doing
puzzles and muting so that it doesn't
echo
yay that was unfortunate dude
that looked rough that looked so
unfortunate for
[Music]
um
or what i'm going to call it um ollie
that was rough i mean sea dog played
i feel like about as well as i expected
him to
find fine okay
doing puzzles to warm up for my match
against
uh
[Music]
in front
are you all ready for one loud person
and then one
other loud person that's slightly less
loud
i'm the slightly less loud one
other than blocks that's not it
[Music]
oh it wasn't that was this
this check
oh i'm pinned
[Music]
um i kind of want to do this and then
protect
[Music]
this
it's this and it's run away like a
scared that's fine
all right
sometimes you gotta be wrong to be right
sometimes you gotta be wrong
but also that sucks
because being wrong hurts um
this is a good move
[Music]
i'm supposed
what does it want me
[Music]
so i don't know what this music i let me
just
let me just go to uh
kerning city i was listening to this
earlier on my other stream
[Music]
hi hood
it's less cute when a bald white guy
does it
it doesn't want me to do this there's no
way doesn't want me to do
this then what else does it want me to
do
all right and we are back with the
players connor
and ali ali i want to ask you if you had
something that you could say to connor
before the match what would it have been
ponder even if you blundered your queen
even if you gave away your queen i know
you would win
so i thought you would go easy on me by
doing that you know
make it the fair game dang it there's a
there's a level gap between us i thought
you do
at least that but you didn't i like like
the chat would know the chat
the chat hurt me begging i was like
connor please
please just give away your queen are you
going to give me your queen
now connor i don't have that many pieces
it'd be really cool if it could at least
donate one of your pieces to me
legit said that uh
yeah uh yeah i gave your queen a second
chance though i don't know if you
if you uh remembered that i did i
remember that
yeah but am i happy no
you're happy ollie
like i know like man
i wanted to i'm retiring from chess
i wanted to uh play you like any other
opponent i wanted to show you
respect dolly and uh unfortunately i
think it looked a bit like bullying but
that's not what i was going for i was
going for
you know i didn't want to disrespect you
by going easy on you and no one else
appreciate it but uh apex right
sir you better carry me you better carry
me to diamond
make it up for me all right that's gonna
be real difficult all right
[Laughter]
maybe we could do that also
a little gift i don't know if you like
roses but
i i yeah i love roses gonna give this to
you
[Laughter]
thank you did you pick them yourself i
did
virtually here you go oh my god oh my
god thank you i should have bought
flowers i could have accepted them
oh my god thank you thank you so much
ollie you're welcome
so um so ali i know that uh uh
yes after yesterday's match we uh got to
share some
artwork with you that the community had
put together and uh
we actually asked them to uh show us
what they thought
of a convergence between rusted
and ollie after yesterday's interview
and uh they rose to the challenge what
do you think
man they're so fast i love the middle
one the middle one is very accurate
it's the middle one
[Laughter]
the middle one is the exact fusion that
i have in my head yeah oh
oh my gosh like islam is lucky
that uh we're not fused yet if i was
fused with dressage
man he's taking the whole tournament
probably
true true true i wonder i wonder if this
is going to inspire the audience to uh
come up with some
some olly c dog fusions but
i think
like actually actually actually can we
have
like everyone fused as ali like even
aaron and jt
too like the whole tournament members
that'd be cool yeah you know what
i i think that's worth some diamond
memberships for chess.com
anyone who does that and tweets that out
and tags chess.com
is going to get a chance at a diamond
membership that's a great idea ali
connor uh obviously you will be moving
on
and you are going to face the winner of
the next
match which is techtone versus esam have
you already started
thinking about what you're gonna do to
prepare for that pairing
in either case yeah so uh
when i play gone in the finals i'm just
gonna play the same and just beat him
this time
that's kind of what i'm kind of what i'm
thinking
makes sense yeah that's that's my game
plan
uh you know seriously though i mean
we'll see i i you know i
feel like esam plays solid [__] yes and
uh
everest plays better than the day we'll
win
i would oh sorry tech yeah sorry uh
that's a close game
um it's gonna be a doozy
either way i i just want i love watching
tattoo and play i'm
kind of sad that we didn't see more tech
tone if tetra loses
listen um he has a hippo on his side
okay honestly it's gonna be
very hard to know that's tricky you kind
of gotta dissect it really carefully
yeah uh so i played a match versus um
one of the best grand masters in the
world and he said he had to study it now
because it might become a threat yeah
like literally
somebody in the top hundred actually in
the top 50. wow
it was picking up steam guys um so i
actually want to
tell ali i when you said you were going
to quit chess i was like
oh no please don't quit because
because of you i started learning
indonesian again
wait you learned indonesian before yeah
yeah i was learning indonesia before and
about
that was just like you know on january
by
um you know stuff like that
uh i i know that song and i can sing it
like almost perfectly i think
and i was learning it because of that
song and then i
just was like okay ollie's doing her
best at chess
so i have to do my best in indonesia so
i i know
i can say like a hundred words right now
in indonesian so i've been really
practicing
i think i put about 10 hours in of study
time
that is so cool well i guess i'll have
to go back to cheshire tonight
it's not helping it i guess i'll go back
to chess
ollie you played in the second game i
felt like you played the best chess that
i've seen you play
like you played slow like
obviously i like you know i i was i was
being mean
but you know i think overall though you
took your time and you made it difficult
like there was just you made the moves
that were annoying to me
[Laughter]
i was sincerely hoping that maybe you
could
maybe maybe i could land in a spot where
you accidentally stale
meat you know i didn't wait but maybe
maybe uh
you know if that uh that that uh you
know that uh super chatter come through
maybe he'd have known you know uh
i guess uh it's too nice
oh dear it's going down
[Laughter]
and connor i really appreciate that you
took your time
in situations where i think you might
have seen the movie almost immediately
but you actually calm down and like i
really appreciate that
because you took my advice and i'm
really happy because that's really going
to help you in the later stages as well
so good job adapting i i saw ollie
versus rusted yesterday
you know ollie you know if you if you
give only an opening all you can do some
damage so
uh i didn't want to actually lose to all
you know offense ollie
because i feel like you would never let
me forget it and neither would my
viewers you're right
like imagine getting beaten up by a
zombie anime girl
i feel like if i did it you know you'd
be like oh you're
you're predator and apex remember that
time i beat you in chester
[Music]
like sorry like premonitions it was like
i've seen the future of like
my suffering to come if i lost one
evening yeah just one game no because
you know
everyone's already bashing on me in the
interviews i can't give them more
reasons too
sir and
in preparation for this match just in
case
watch out watch out
he's got the guns she's pulling weapons
on us now
fine i
i was like um okay i'll learn some welsh
but then i gave up
it's too hard why it's easy it's easy
say congratulations then
yeah exactly no i'm not saying that
yeah it's kind of hard
well uh ali i think obviously
unfortunately this means that you
are exiting the tournament with us
tonight but there's some good news
you have actually earned some prize
money to help buy back your family home
from that ramen shop what do you think
hell yes i can finally bribe the ramen
guy
awesome i don't need to become an idol
to do that
thank you so much for being so
understanding
how many how many packs are you gonna
buy with that
um um
connor connor please okay okay sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry
but thank you again both of you
obviously ali i we all hope that you
stick with chess
and we hope that you enjoyed
participating in the tournament as well
and uh thank you so much uh any any
parting words maybe
let us know who you're gonna be rooting
for in the grand final
it was really really fun first of all
and i want to thank you everyone for
having me here and for being so kind and
supportive
uh a big thanks to aaron and also gt
a big thanks also to connor for for uh
making this happen
you better win this i'm gonna
i'm gonna try you better get again
finals or else i'll be
really salty i'll get my muslim beak out
and i'll be sure to knock you
in down firing range if you don't get
the grand finals
all right i i'll i'll try my best i'm
going to get to the final i'm going to
win
i'm going to do it good because i lost
my one month of apex
i saw you playing though no the
the one month ban uh starts in august so
oh my god no
oh it's real though
[Laughter]
you better win okay okay i will try my
best all right
there you have it connor moves on
and we unfortunately say goodbye to
ollie but
she will be with us in spirit as she
roots for connor to
continue to make her way through the
tournament and uh
all right conor will now face the winner
of the next pairing between techtone and
esam so
jt our next match is coming up
what do you got to say
oh man it's going to be uh the lightning
fast
esam versus the legend himself
tech tone with the hippo strat i
i'm excited i'm honestly excited i
wonder because i know esam
probably prepared for this match and i'm
wondering if it's preparation is going
to do any good because the hippo is
pretty
solid so i wonder if tekton is going to
be able to adapt slightly his opening
prep um and i'm super excited because it
can go both ways right because the hippo
can just
annihilate opponents or the hippo can
you know maybe be a little bit too
passive and
but i think i think that sexton
is going to embody the spirit of the
hippo and do well and
it does santa break those walls
this really is gonna be interesting to
see how esam deals
with uh with techtone's opening prep it
definitely
put on a show for us against kizzy k and
uh
we're gonna find out in just a moment
because i believe the players are both
getting ready
we will take a short break and when we
come back the second match of the day
uh esam versus tech tone see you guys in
a sec
in 30 men battle of the bald boys
bald blundering boys
bless the goal okay
[Music]
hype train uh
sub if you think i even have a
snowball's
chance in hell to win this i have not
looked at esam's match history because i
have looked at nobody's match history
because if i win i want to win with
hippo and hippo alone we're going to
hope that he blunders his queen
that's the strap
that's the strat you tant about a lot
it's the only way to win
of course yes of course
all right take this [__] sheesh
bro my pulse is like five thousand
boys let's go all right cool
notice notice how nobody subbed that's
because nobody [__] believes bro
if you were to ready let's begin in five
minutes
yes sir
[Music]
hippo gang
rise up all right let's practice uh
play congratulations one minute let's go
[Music]
you die tonight you don't want to do
this coward
you don't want to do this
[Music]
the [__] you gonna do okay and then what
what [__] you gonna do a little [__]
stand aside coward walk away
i better beat your ass
uh why okay [__] yep
[__] you gonna do
[Music]
yup rocket thrusters activate
[__] [__] what you gonna do
take it for free damn foiled again
yoink oh [__]
well don't do that that's not cool bro
[__] that's [__] vile sheesh
what the [__] yo you're gonna take my
horse for free yo that's [__]
oh my god he's killing me dude
jesus well what if you do if i go right
he's gonna take my queen do it coward
yes sweat you [__] york
thank you [__]
[Music]
how fast can we go
uh yup we're gonna do kill me
yoik thank you
[__] yup
bye bye oh [__] give me that
[__] i was doing so good oh dude we were
actually we were doing okay
that is uh the vibe has
changed i will put it that way jt
the vibe has shifted
but the hippo is real the hippo's real
the hip was so good
and it's probably the realist thing
uh mankind has ever seen and i'm glad
that teki
is uh the ambassador chosen
for this opening yes definitely and he's
also going to get the white pieces in
the first game which is going to start
any moment
and again the stakes are high we are in
the redemption arc
portion of the event where everyone who
loses any of these matches they're out
that's it that's their last match so
one of these players is going home the
other one is going to move on
then face sea dog va and then there's
another match the loser final and then
whoever wins that goes the grand final
whoever wins that wins four thousand
dollars and becomes the champion of
turnover too
and then my therapy begins
just in time for tonight three right am
i right exactly the second i recover
from all of the from all of everything
that came with this tournament
we'll start number three and we're also
going to start this game which should be
uh momentarily if the players are ready
then we are going to kick this thing off
uh reminder everyone both players will
start with 10 minutes on
their clocks and they will gain 5
seconds for every move
this match has to go to somebody getting
to 2 points
and then they will win if somehow they
play three games
and they end up with one and a half
points apiece then they will go into a
tiebreaker
which we have seen multiple times so far
in this event
uh where they will play three-minute
chess with no increment
i would really love to see how the hippo
holds up against esam in a three minute
game
oh man i mean you saw a bullet so you
saw
he was able to get the hippo strap it's
just a little bit slower
right so
[Music]
okay there's just speech train needs
more coal
i don't back bro i told people to only
sub or donate on this type train
if they actually thought i even had a
one percent chance of winning we all
know esam's gonna beat the [__] out of
me
okay we all know he's going to beat the
[__] out of me okay
if i even if i even get
one of his pieces i'll be happy okay
joe ty gets it oh we're going first man
let's go okay my only mode uh alert's
off
let's go
[Music]
okay you're lucky you got a couple
seconds for free you're welcome
don't do triple pawn ford you [__] did
you look up my mad history you [__]
if he moves the pawn to c5 we lose
[Music]
oh
no this is good wait hold up don't move
on that you [__] okay no we're safe
good good second there
for a second there i thought we were
about to get rustaged again
everybody
oh my [__] heart skipped to be i was
about to
break my goddamn monitor i want to know
what getting rusted
is is like
let's find out what uh the perspective
is like from esam street i don't know
what i'm doing i'm kind of just
okay let me slow down anything let me
actually
play the game um
this uh if i go forward that's fine and
if
i do this they take and i
take and they take and i take and take
so they win
and i just want to do this push this and
then get my rook here and then if they
do this rook
nothing changes but fun
it is a very very good move
i gotta not play like i'm just [__]
around because i'm definitely playing
like it's casual and i should not
do that
what is happening what
i like how he was perplexed by that king
move he was like what is happening
yeah and here we have a very very nice
idea um for white
and so hopefully we can see it so
in some cases this attack
might be because this is attacking the
knight that's undefended and also this
knight
going here would attack this knife
that's undefended
that is a cool move here
here we it kind of spells trouble wait a
minute
it's not equal it's about equal
okay black playing e4 something is amiss
here
uh but man it's kind of hard to see
what what's happening jt
so i i believe that just taking here and
taking here would be
the best idea but
right now just just taking back and i
think
the position's so solid remember we
don't have to play flashy plays even if
there's
like the best move if you just follow
set play yeah you're just going to
be in a good shape and that's why i love
the hippo because even
with you just following the ideas you
get good positions now
imagine if you were just to say okay
well this is a free pun let me just take
it
then then you get into a better position
yeah it seems like the
natural worst position the natural moves
are uh what makes this
a bit easier to play but oh man f4
f4 the yeah exactly
he's definitely gonna see this if you
talk there i can't do [__] about it i
ain't gonna cap
right if you take that that's all that's
all you boo boo
i could go there and take it that'd be
kind of funny
would it do anything good not really uh
let's fork them
chose what would you like to die for the
first
i will die upon your [__] soul
tonight
who dies your night or thine queen
one of them will be basking in the blood
in the guts
you shall die where you stand
will you choose will you go on the
offensive who knows
now let me get that pony boy yoink
thank you bet that [__] hurt don't it
bet that [__] hurt they'll be writing
about that [__] in the history books
in the history books that one time issan
realized
stop that
wait no i'm not having fun anymore
stop it i'm not having fun okay
you take that i'm [__]
okay you take that i i'm [__] you take
that i'm [__]
oh chill dude [__] that's a game bro
down
guess i could realize that he's also up
a piece right now and taking another
piece on d6 would be
really good go there
yeah i mean look techy techy's gonna do
what tech he's gonna do
and he finds good moves he doesn't find
others
but that man he played f4
that was that was impressive
exactly this is this is another good
move this is this is a good move
this i'm actually surprised that tech he
is finding all the correct moves in the
position
um
knight d4 was strong i also like bishop
f3 and here
we just have to we we just have to
create our pieces right we're up pieces
when we're up pieces we trade pieces
wow this is very wild this is wild i
don't know
that i would say i i honestly expected
this i mean esam
has shown such strong chess
i i was like shocked even when giga
defeated him but like i
was anybody expecting techtone to come
out the
gate like this against esam was isam
expecting it we have to hear
i want to check here
okay so he sees tektone can move his
bishop with
a tempo against this queen he's trying
to work out
how scary that may or may not be
he's looking at the right move here
yeah it changes the dynamic of that
situation
to where if i don't move triple checking
that i'm not like back ranking myself
it's actually bad yeah
and seems like techy may have let this
one go
wow jt i have to say though it's it's
promising to see what techie was
able to do in those opening moves
um that was impressive i i think maybe
esam
had to slow down a little bit he even
said himself like
i have to stop playing this like it's
casual because
he's actually putting some serious
pressure
and i can't just assume that this is
given
right um and i think tucky
needs to spend a little bit more time
when he's up to really
like understand the position and convert
because the hardest time
to play a good chess is when you're up
it's the hardest
time to win actually and you need to
really take a lot of time you need to
really take some focus
and we see that esam has disconnected
for a little bit
but it seems like he is back online but
luckily for him tekton has not made a
move yet
so i mean there's only really one move
here you have to give back the bishop
and
the the move should be uh
rook g1 but let's see what techie yeah
let's see what happens
one space forward i'd take it i can't
take it
then he moves down and he has been
checkmate okay
so then i'm gonna do this move instead
[Music]
and now i force him to take my [__] and
then hopefully we get a piece off the
board
i think this is probably a fine move is
that i have it guarded with my bishop
i need to get my queen online though
that do be a problem
it do it do it do be a problem
oh i can't take that
okay
oh wait do i lose i might lose here i
might lose here
can't take that because he has the queen
if i go here then he just brings the
queen here right and then i just lose
no i think i lose i think that's
checkmate man
let's go he's down let's [__] go
[Music]
baby
wow wow uh
that that was a game that there was a
game
that was a game indeed um the hippo
proved to be effective
was able to get a piece out of the
opening the a piece the whole piece on
esam one of the strongest contestants
right and had a great position
with pieces in you know until end
just couldn't convert and i hope that
you know we can take a little bit more
time next time in the next
match and i'm not saying that he's going
to get an opening advantage but
just take your time in general yeah yeah
i mean techno definitely showed that he
does have what it takes to get safely
into the game against esam or pretty
much everybody i mean that he's played
it with so far
um and maybe he'll make some adjustments
in the break that we're about to take
uh for game two of techtone versus esam
this thing is not written already it
could go either way so
stick around and find out
is that
i guess i guess it frees up like yep
nope that's way better
yeah i had my queen locked up that was
my issue and from there on it was just
it's snowballed out of control oh that
was dope i think next time i just need
to uh
not lock up my queen and play like
someone who's not a [__] idiot
uh and then if we do those two things
then we'll probably get a w
or or we'll lose and if we lose
then it's okay because i still made it
past the first elimination
which is honestly a [__] shock so
to be honest it's already pretty much
like we won the [__] lottery that a
[__] like me didn't lose first
i don't think anybody saw it coming that
i was not being a dead
[__] last oh that is what it is
hey the good news is we're having fun
and that's what my mom and pop said
as long as you're fun having as long as
you having fun techie jk they were
divorced
and they said well at least you still
have two christmases
they got me underwear for christmas
they didn't even know that i didn't wear
underwear when i was a kid
because it hurt me because my ass was
too fat back then
and i was fat
that's why i play the hippos that's why
i play the hippo strat
that way i don't have to internalize the
pain i have to feel for being [__]
fat
jesus christ somebody give me a [__]
bag of [__] carrots
and some celery bro
that's all right bro we may have lost
that one
but losing is half the battle now here's
the part where esam lets me win unless
he's a [__]
jerk don't be a dick esam
don't be a dick let me win once huh
bro if you don't let me win dude my
cat's not gonna get any treats tonight
because i won't be able to afford it bro
i i went to vegas man i bet all my
currency yo i need money for my cat bro
please
oh yes oh man
yeah does anybody actually believe me
for the next round
i always want to stay on my [__] dude
if i lose and it says zero next to my
name i'm going to have actual depression
come on come on hey sam throw me a
[__] bone here hold up let me let me
mess with you sam
yo let me win this one trust it would be
funny
[Music]
hear me out on move 14 blunder your
queen
trust bro
it'll be hilarious
[Laughter]
come on it'll be hilarious
it's on move 14 just [__]
hey man at least you might have
good luck
dope what a homie dude what a homie
what a bro
[Laughter]
he actually thinks that i have a chance
of winning that's flattering
that is exactly what he said
he said said no i'm not giving this to
you
man that is just hilarious um
so let's see if the players are going to
take more time now and issa now has
tasted the hippo i wonder if he's not
going to take it seriously or is he
going to
feel like it's a casual match i mean the
match is going to start underway
he sam had a chance right there in the
discord to say he could throw for
content for a game three and he was not
willing to take that risk
so they're off the game has started and
uh let's uh listen
he said just made a mistake in the
opening oh
that's why you slide
[Music]
he doesn't seem too upset right now
maybe it really hasn't settled yet
yeah i don't know i mean i think maybe
he's
trying to go for like a quick check me
but i don't think it's going to
work i mean was he going to go for like
uh oh wait no he can
you'd want to put well maybe you could
put your queen on h5 right and try to
try to trick him i mean he asked
remember
h6 and g6 on
[Music]
oh man because he's not letting me
want to play g6 we want to play e6 we
want to play h6 anyways right so
yeah you just gave us an extra move we
don't care what you're trying to play
well he has d5 he has to he has to pay
attention we have d5 in the position
oh d5 would hit the knight and the
bishop
[Music]
but it's okay it's that play it's that
play
one space interesting i want to kill
that [__] horse so bad i can't i can
barely think straight
good castle dude
love to see it
i go there oh if i move there i get my
bishop there he does not have any guard
for this pawn
yes he does it's called the [__]
queen attacked on you [__] ugly [__]
jesus christ when you're so [__]
stupid i can almost puke
i mean good luck good luck for for one
second could you not [__] up for once in
your entire goddamn life
get your [__] [__] together techy he
has a [__] queen
jesus christ you make me sick
techtone is delivering the external
monologue
that i feel like i have internally every
time i play chess
and i still love it somehow
oh my gosh there is another blunder here
he has blundered twice on e4 he has
blundered
twice on e4 guys is he throwing for
content
[__] he's sorry for content or what
i was just trying to move these pawns
man he did not see it he's shocked
bro uh dude i don't know about y'all i'm
like
i'm like gigging down i'm gigging down
to trade bishops
i am good down to trade bishops
what say you in your defense what say
you
jt the hippo is the hippo is real
the hippo is real it's taking down
one of the top seeds in this tournament
and
whoa i didn't expect the hippo to be so
powerful i like i gave him
i gave him the tools and the weapon and
now he's just like actually this is how
you really play jt
let me let me show you he's
wow dude he techtone has a lot of moves
here
like he's got he's got this game
like if if he if he now kind of
calms down realizes that he's doing
great
and just makes quality moves blunder
checks himself is this a safe square for
my pieces
you know then uh he can carry this one
home i think
yeah i mean all he has to do is keep
trading down and
he's already up you know a piece and a
pawn and
and essentially more because the
position is also favoring
black here because there are a lot of
breaks um
i think the idea here is oh well i mean
here's another pawn i mean here we we
should just recapture this way because
you're basically saying
i'm going to recapture and i'll take
your queen trades are favorable when
we're off pieces
right when you're up pieces you trade
pieces
and look at this look at this now when
we take right
take take notice that you cannot take
with this rook
because this rook would then be oh wow
wow and okay that was close
that would have been spicy oh man and
now look though
uh esam has found a resource here
pinning
techie's knight to the rook
he's gonna have to be resourceful like
this to stay in this game
maybe goes like this
this this
start winning some of my [__] back
[Music]
okay techtone finds a decent move adding
a defender
mm-hmm if that tune can find
the amazing move knight d5 he'd be in
really good shape as well
i don't know if he's accounted for that
[Music]
funny thing is i actually did almost
blunder my queen at the beginning of the
game
like when i was being cheesy i was like
i guess like
once i did this i was like oh i'm just
gonna go here
like i'm just going to go my queen there
and the bishop was still covering it and
i was like oh
[Music]
techtone seems like he's not sure how to
address this let's take a look
what if i do this instead trade
trade it i want your rook
i am leaving here with your [__] rook
i'm gonna take that [__] i'm ahead you
[__] dirty dog
you dirty dog
okay so you're gonna be like that huh
i can go here and put him in shack
and then he has the spot attacked again
damn me sam you [__] nutty bro jesus
what awareness i think i just need to
move this bishop somewhere
but i don't know where i think moving my
bishop here would be good
if anything kills i can take it back but
then he grabs my rook which would suck
or maybe bishop a6 hit him with a taste
of his own medicine pin
his knight to his rook
all right i really like that idea bishop
v6 was actually a very
nice and it's quality here um
so now all e7 has to find is bishop
takes e7 and
he is back in the game um
not a hard move to find but definitely
when you're under pressure and you've
been down
okay there we go special captures on e7
and all we have to do is special
catchers on 97 let's see what e7 is
thinking
it looks more comfortable
[Music]
we made it back to even
another edition of the tournament r2
soundtrack coming to you uh
in stores friday
[Music]
you have upseti the spaghetti
that's my favorite one so far
and that was probably e sam's favorite
combo so far in this game he's got a
piece back
and now they're yeah
even on material right i got a bishop
we got rooks we got pawns we both have
kings that's still true
that was test jt
you passed thank you
you're welcome um here they're kind of
letting the
um the attention go because now you just
gave on
even though this wasn't even trade this
one is it oh and now
coming in saying i'm gonna take another
pawn
yep with check and tech tone
yo
he's still thinking about wanting traits
but not realizing this is how he sam's
good and i know he's good
the question is how good do we really
think this guy
is
nothing how do we i don't know this is
gonna be [__] hard as [__] to play
from
uh maybe we just continue moving pieces
up
is there any dope position where i can
actually get ahead i don't think so
let's see maybe we can maybe we can get
a stalemate
we were doing really good i don't want
to go from there which sucks
[Music]
yeah the problem with that thought is
that there are just
too many ways that e sam can get the
material needed
hold on hold on there there's this
sneaky sneaky trap here
well that's not one of them but uh the
idea was to play bishop c4
and then e stem has to find rook a7
but here we're just trading and well the
bishop
is better than the knight in end games
where the plays on two sides
but in this case they're just up two
pawns and they're two pass pawns
connected past pawns
pass bonds means that there is nothing
in front of the pawns
and it's going to be hard because you
have a
weaknesses as well and that e5
that e4 pawn move came way too early you
got to bring the king over first
protect the pawns that you want to pass
and uh
white is going to get there in time to
stop it
in some positions we might even
sacrifice this knight
for this pawn because these two pawns
are going to be
too strong and maybe these coupons are
going to be too strong yeah
potential potential yeah and
unfortunately
i think in both cases techtone
was winning easily in the opening stages
of both games
and unfortunately where he fell short
is just simply in converting that
advantage into a win
he had the right idea in this game of
realizing when he was up material to
start trading but then unfortunately
what happened
aside from just the blunder that we saw
of the rook
was that he continued to believe the
trading was the right
way forward even after material became
equal
would you say that's about right
i would say that's absolutely correct i
i think that
um he was too focused on trading and
he's like well i'm up let's
trade which is the correct way to go
about things but
i think he was too focused on trading
and maybe not to you know focus on
taking advantage of his
his positioning he had an amazing
position his position was
one of the best positions i've seen in
the whole tournament in the opening this
the huge lead um and
hopefully i mean my favorite word is
tell me and i'm still rooting for it but
i want to see what techie's feeling
right now
yeah let's take a listen
you really [__] it up this time didn't
you techy
you really [__] it on up
dude if he stalemates this [__] that
would be [__] hilarious
how do i get him the stalemate this
would be so
funny if he stalemates well i think i
don't think he will though
let's see though do you know how to do
this
are you that smarty sam are you that
much smarter than me
i think he is
okay he's moving really quick which
it makes me believe that he's confident
let's go sam
let's go that's what i'm talking about
bro good [__] dude
okay are you ever that happy for your
opponents
when they beat you
um so not in tournaments but sometimes
in blitz i'm just like
good job
i need to try that i need to try that
next tournament i'll get up and i'll
just
i'll i'll give him like a little bow a
little like how
how would you say that in japanese if
you want to show respect for somebody
who's defeated you
that you bow okay so
my my japanese was perfect there
good job in japanese it was great
i've been studying i've been studying
all right guys we're gonna we're gonna
take a break here
we're gonna interview the players we'll
be back in just a few minutes
esam moves on tectonic is eliminated
we'll find out how they both feel about
it
just a sec be right back
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
all right and we are back with uh with
happy sam and evil
slash uh uh
uh monaco something something's going on
there well you know what i'm
impressed depressed is the word you're
looking for
he sam i want to start with you dude
techtone offered you the deal of a
lifetime
between games one and two
i won so it's not like anything happened
i gave you a free knight but not a queen
that's true that was dope we appreciated
that that was we
the royal we of course the royal okay
okay okay yes
yes uh esam why didn't you take the deal
man
is there something that happened in game
one that made you go like wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait
let me well so i remember
before the game uh jt is that okay if i
call you that is that
yeah that's totally fine um was like oh
esam's probably done his prep and i'm
just like
i have not so i was uh like game one
threw me off a little bit and i like
messed up a bit with like letting him do
the pawn fork and i was like okay well
even though i'm confident that i will
win i have to not mess up and then i
immediately messed up and i was just
like
you'll love this [__] like
[Laughter]
but i i have too much i have respect
i'm not good enough a chance to just
beat people for free for super easy and
just throw away a queen
yeah and i mean i think rightly so
because
uh techtone you were actually
objectively winning
in the early stages of both games i mean
did you
did you uh did you have a sense of that
yeah i did i was like dude i'm killing
it
killing it can't wait to [__] this
and i up you the fact that you did yeah
i was like man i'm doing great
how many turns until i just completely
[__] the bad chance
like four yeah like four was about four
hours fair when you when you blundered
that pawn on game two i was stoked i was
over the moon dude oh that was jumping
for joy
yeah i get that i respect that i
understand you see an opponent as weak
as me
sam you're like you know what this guy's
trash i'll beat this guy with my eyes
though but i'm playing on a robot i'm
gonna pre-move like uh
what's that dude's name knocking wait
there's a really good player guy
can't remember that guy's name like
pre-moved like 34 turns in a row and
like checkmates magnus
something like that it was a dark video
i watched it was probably fake but it
was what it
i believe it i'm still a believer you
said it was fake i still believe it it's
fine
good uh uh okay out of curiosity j.t
what's up what'd you think are you
serious look at your opening
you got advantages out of the opening
and this is what we prepped
yeah what more could you ask you played
it perfectly thank you
for two weeks a little bit less than
that yeah around then
right and you played perfectly and you
you were
winning against one of the top seeds in
the tournament yeah i i remember
i remember yesterday i'm not sure if you
saw the comment i was like sweet get to
fight kissy k on who's going to lose the
east salmon
it was really funny i mean i appreciate
your confidence in me
but like you were i've never seen hippo
before it was
surprisingly hard to deal with so you
you
had me on the back foot and then i got
like the like you gave me like one turn
that was i was able to do something i
were like you messed i don't remember
how game two i ended up getting in favor
uh oh it's like huge everything on the
seventh
rank uh yeah but like it was
terrifying like i said to my chat after
i lost i'm like damn so
if you just like were a little like a
little bit more solid you probably at
least won one of those games
i was hoping for at least one
unfortunate didn't happen but we were
hoping but
i we i played the best chess i could it
was very fitting
because uh back when i first met my wife
forever ago
i was actually studying your pikachu
games in order to beat her in smash
and now the very person who taught me
how to compete against my wife in smash
has now destroyed me some eight ten
years later comes full circle
it's you know positives and negatives
unless
the you beating her led to arguments in
which case negatives and negatives
uh my fox your pikachu would you play
techie you play pikachu as well oh i
play ganondorf
oh no you can get out of here
yeah i like i like fox fox has always
been my character since melee
that's cause he's broken bro when you
play the sweaty characters dog you just
i think i'm the sweaty one here i don't
know jt he's like diamond in rocket
league like
20 billion and says dude obliterates
every game he plays
it's very intimidating but you know what
i feel like something that maybe you can
take away from this techie
is that you've learned from chess
that you now just have to seek the hippo
in
in whatever it is that you do in life
and you will crush right off the gate
sounds very true another yeah no i agree
another thing i'll be taking away uh
from chess is a big fat
[__] l from today's match
[Music]
you got some prize money to spend on
those new geeks
i like i totally i totally forgot about
the prize money i was literally doing
this just for fun i had a i had a blast
every single okay
well then we won't give it to you how
about that right hey hey give it to jt
give him these
i was just doing that i mean this [__]
was so fun it does suck
that i'm leaving i'm actually i actually
am pretty damn bummed to live because uh
i really wanted to get i'll allow you to
say hi to my buddy garrett
but is what it is maybe a tournament arc
three
but the people who i met in this tutor
so cool like especially somebody like me
i never thought i'd be able to do
something cool like this so
this was a this was a big like event for
my
i guess content creation and not to
mention now i have a game
that i actually feel challenged in and
playing like with chess i was telling jt
this when i first started playing
about two odd weeks ago there's barely
any games where i actually feel
challenged in playing anymore
but chess i just felt like an idiot
every goddamn time i played and i love
that feeling i love feeling stupid
it's like really nice i mean pokemon
unite came out that game slaps
but you should it's so fun uh but jess
so good i'm gonna keep this game going
forever i can't play i'm gonna play this
[__]
with my children i'm going to play this
with my i don't have them yet
but i will one day and i'll learn from
this day you you
aaron and jt you have indirectly given
me time to uh bond with my children
and i for that i'm eternally grateful
if that's the only thing i've done with
my life i'm happy techy
i'm happy esam i want to ask you
last question uh esam vs cdoc va
you have however much time you have to
get ready for that what are you going to
do well tomorrow
um well god in my practice games today
i wasn't playing great and i blundered a
decent amount today literally i think i
had a lower accuracy rating today than
versus either giga
or sagam so i really just need to like
play better maybe study some of his
openings i don't know if he repeats his
openings
uh because like obviously i know that
you know especially from
competitive gaming background and smash
prep is really important
and sea dogs no no no offense techie
uh sea dog's one hell of an opponent and
uh i think we are pretty equal
so i need to do my due diligence or at
the very least
play better and also probably study a
little bit
uh but it's hard it's going to be
difficult uh obviously i think me
him and giggup were the top three seeds
so if i beat
uh whoever wins out of me and sea dog i
think is going to meet gigguk in the
grand finals just based off of seating
and raiding and if i'm wrong i'm wrong
and that's totally cool
well i'm not trying to throw shots at
anyone just you know i'm always someone
that looks ahead in bracket because it's
part of my job
uh but it's going to be uh
difficult tomorrow it's going to be
really fun i hope it's as fun of a match
that i had versus gig except i hope i
win this time also
so i know before they make me sign off
uh techy your energy
is amazing your interviews and the
when they cut to your stream it's
absolutely fantastic your energy both in
the discord and just on your streams
is wonderful thank you i appreciate that
let's see oh and also also full offense
taken to your previous jab and saying
i'm not going to the opponent
i hope sea dog eats you alive
oh my gosh that's valid um
wait ethan what did you do who did you
even lose to you oh wait you lost a dick
oh [__] no that was crazy close like
literally if i moved my king like one
different direction i won
yeah i'm cause like oh my god if you win
and then you face giggle again for the
rematch
that's what i'm saying yeah that's gonna
be crazy
oh my god
somebody needs to take giga down because
that dude's ego is skyrocketing right
now he is the true super villain of this
tournament so
or the protag depending on how you think
about it yeah that's true there's just
there's so many good matchups that can
be happening soon i mean every match
from here on out is gonna be so heated
isn't everything before villains
supposed to be the hero of their own
story is that
that's how people say it just got deep i
have no idea that's that's deep dude
well tech tone unfortunately this means
that you're out of tournament arc two
but i have to say okay if there's a
tournament arc three
right conor got his redemption arc to
get into tournament arc too
what is techies arc in ta3
i'm telling you this right now okay
if i get let's say determine arc happens
in a year
do you know how much i'm going to
explode in strategy
and prowess for the next tournament
it's i'll bring ten goddamn hippos just
imagine if i have more time to repair if
i have more time to practice
and i'm going to i really feel like i
can be a true contender next this this
time i was
i'm a side character you know what i
mean like i'm like brock
or misty in pokemon one day maybe i'll
be james who knows
but i i would love if there was a
tournament this has been one of the
funnest things i've ever done so
you you say you need me i'm there
i will bring it back
i think you're the more like guy i think
you're more like guy from naruto
you haven't unleashed the seals yet
right that's
holding you down and then when you come
back you you take that moderate right
that's the plan that's the plan
[Music]
and he said what um where to advice um
a little bit slower right like i know
yeah
yeah i was like right like
you you're playing good moves and you
have good moves but you're just like you
have to blunder check stuff
you can't just play music you think
you're better than the european i think
you were taking a little bit too easy
and that hurts strong players as well
it's something like oh my opponent let's
say you're like 2700 and your opponent's
1800 okay maybe you make a blunder now
you have to work even harder instead of
just playing your
your your plan right for sure i'm
definitely used to um
i'll go ahead no go ahead i'm definitely
you know
in chess everyone's equal but i'm
definitely also used to having a broken
character that i don't have to think
about when i'm just better than people
i'm just like i'm just gonna
go through the motions and just beat
people because i'm top 15 in the world
uh but that doesn't work in chess no one
cause i'm not the top 15 in the world
and two
everyone's the same like you can always
just win
and uh techy it's been it was a pleasure
coaching you and you still
have me on discord just hitting me up
whenever i'm
willing to do chats maybe genjin uh
at some point and um thank you so much
for bringing so much energy to the
tournament and
it's sad to see you go but i hope that
we see you again and
that are passed across again it was
amazing thank you so much
and i appreciate that tried to do
everything i could this was dope thank
you for having me
thank you so much techy and esam we'll
see you tomorrow have a good night guys
good night
there you have it folks techtone
departs but i gotta say he definitely
is in the top running for a fan favorite
here in tournament arc 2 and uh
wow now we've got two
serious matches ahead of us jt
this it's just when you think
that it cannot get the story lines can't
get
more like you know though you know when
when goku is just standing
there in the arena with cell and you
know the next
episode is the one where they're finally
going to start exchanging real blows
this is that like this is the commercial
break
before rustage v giga determines
who's in the grand final and then esam
versus sea dog
which i would say sea dog was the
favorite in turn mark one
e sam's probably maybe in some respects
still the favorite
though he did lose to giga in tournament
r2
like what do you think
mouth vomit over you go um
so the one gear versus rustage that's
going to be a sight to see because who
no matter who wins
there's going to be a lot of hype around
it because if russage wins
and let's say c dog gets all the way to
rostig then
they're gonna have kind of like a
revenge match from tony mark one
right if giga wins and let's say
sea dog wins then it's the fight that
everybody wants to see
right it's they've been trash talking
each other they've been going
back and forth back and forth and
i'm just thinking what happens if rusted
wins
and esem wins then that's going to be
kind of crazy and what if giga queens
and
issan wins now they fight again so
there's just so many possibilities
in this racket that all of them are
super super hyped and i know the chat is
going to be even better because
they're all looking at these games
they're all preparing they're all going
for it
and i just can't wait for it for these
matches it's been
an amazing time and we've had so much
energy and thank you so much to the chat
for
being amazing thank you so much to
twitter for the fan art i really
appreciate it during the break i saw
something of me ollie rn
oh no is it already out it's already out
it's already going thank you so much for
the fan art i really appreciate it you
guys
um you guys have been so amazing and the
energy that we've received from you i
think
um is just so amazing and i feel like
i need to do better as a commentator
just to
live up to your expectation and live up
to what you guys have been putting into
this show so thank you guys so much for
that
and we'll see you tomorrow as well any
last remarks aren't
well we'll see you still tonight right
because jt is going to continue and
stream is that right
oh that is true yeah we have the after
party stream right here yeah we have the
after party on my stream at
social media japanese tutor we'll be
talking about some tormentor stuff we'll
have a lesson and we'll also have some
japanese so
i'll see you there okay yeah guys uh
stick around if you're on twitch stay
with the raid if you're not on twitch
what are you doing go to twitch.tv slash
japanese tutor
join in we'll see you guys tomorrow for
uh
part one of the conclusion of tournament
arc one
let's go
[Music]
my
you